il ne fait pas forcément bon vieillir il
ya quelques jours quelques semaines
maintenant deux semaines par dans
catherine deneuve s'en est pris au
journaliste laurent delahousse lui
reprochant un mauvais sujet qui lui
était consacrée coup de gueule virulent
qui n'est pas sans rappeler ceux
d'autres anciennes gloires de cinéma qui
se lâche maintenant mais c'est
incroyable notamment deux par dieu et
d'autres caisses parce que se passe-t-il
avec nos anciennes gloires est ce qu'ils
se lâchent plus qu'ils ont raison le
faire ou à ce qu'il devienne un peu
aigri regarder on connaissait les
tontons flingueurs il y a maintenant les
anciennes gloires des zincs 2
celle qui du haut de leur grand âge ne
se gêne pas pour dire ce qu'elle pense
au risque de choquer la 30 championne à
ce petit jeu c'est catherine deneuve
elle fait ce qu'elle veut
on va voir contre sandra mais la
ressource mais surtout elle dit ce
qu'elle veut comme ici après la
diffusion de l'émission un jour un
destin qui lui était consacrée elle a
détesté paf elle en plâtre directement
laurent delahousse dans une lettre
adressée à télérama
voilà un enterrement de première classe
vous auriez pu attendre quelques années
encore apport très superficiel et
morbide une vie survoler un mélange
navrant de fiction et de documents réels
s'est indigné et bling alors en prends
toi ça dans la figure surtout que michel
drucker qui lui non plus n'a plus rien à
prouver à personne avait déjà commencé
le travail
laurent delahousse n'est pas un mec bien
il a demandé ma place pendant dix ans
chaque saison est menacée la chaîne de
partir s'il n'avait pas le 19 heures il
a été d'une inélégance incroyable c'est
même le ballon d'or de la discipline en
mode papy dézingueur il ya aussi bien
sûr gérard depardieu qui n'en rate pas
une pour cent plâtre et ceux qui
n'aiment pas comme les journalistes
ils leur préfèrent clairement vladimir
poutine ou kim jong-hun et s'en fiche
totale de ce qu'on peut en penser
polnareff n'aime pas pascal obispo
il le dit alain delon vomi la france
d'aujourd'hui il le dit brigitte bardot
n'estime pas nicolas hulot elle le
traite carrément de trouillards de
première classe
face à ces monstres sacrés qui se lâche
vous êtes choqués ils pas choquer delon
depardieu bardot les anciennes gloires
se lâche c'est ce que vous êtes choqués
ou pas loi c'est pas en dansant gorce et
des superstars pardon superstar des
grandes gloires cela choquer ou pas
catherine choquet pourquoi ouais je suis
un peu choqué je mets de neuf à part
parce que je pense que regarder un film
sur sa propre vie un document
sédimentaires sa propre au but va être
très difficile donc je mets à part sa
réaction sur de la house pour le reste
pour moi c'est de l'incontinence verbale
en lançant un président mais il se lâche
que ça depardieu bardot enfin ça devient
indécent et insupportable ces espèces de
je m'en foutisme sebala il nous encombre
avec leur incontinence verbale macias
est choquée parce que la scapa petit
côté maintenant je suis star j'ai plein
de fric donc j'aime j'ai plus rien alors
attendons une autre choqué c'est magali
berda rhinois jour j'étais allé à monaco
dans une soirée pour une association
caritative qui avait rencontré catherine
deneuve j'ai voulu faire une photo avec
elle gentiment parce que c'est quand
même une anecdote de conseil m'a dit ok
mais par contre vous approchez pas de
moi j'y mets ça va des tatouages
sam la rue cela peut être quand même la
photo bah en fait on cherche à vélo et
en plus c'est cher vous est normal de
rigueur nabila kelly et shona et qui
grâce aux habitudes et autres une avec
magali magail ici
magali site le patron tu peux pas juger
quelqu'un parce qu'une personne peut
être ce jour là fait rimer refuser
l'entrée mais pourquoi ils sont au
dessus des autres en fait il faut que
tout le monde se mette à la même hauteur
mais tu sais ce que c'est que d'être une
attente alors ça c'est un pas non je ne
sais pas ce que c'est excuse moi mais
non mais c'est pas ça c'est que tout le
monde tout le temps estiment que tu peux
la déranger tu peux lui parler en bien
des points noirs et d'associations des
négociations fini des eaux noires dont
je t'adore au balo pu faire tout le
débat autour du pana kelly berdaoui est
ce que vous êtes choqués ou pas par le
fait que ces gloires aujourd'hui on ne
se lâche ou depardieu voilà tous
alors oui pas choquer mais un bien fou
parce que quand on débute dans le métier
on appelle non n'ose pas dire des choses
et on parle des tontons flingueurs il ya
la phrase audiard les cons ça ose tout
c'est même à ça qu'on les reconnaît là
mais voilà alors les vieux ça ose tout
c'est même à ça qu'on les reconnaît et
tant mieux c'est libère à sa salle
bieber à paris et alors ce qu'il faut
quand même remarquer c'est que la
plupart la de ce conte site était déjà
quand même un peu tontons flingueurs
avant catherine deneuve a toujours dit
ce qu'elle pensait c'est une des rares
on cite gérard depardieu qui a toujours
dit n'importe quoi quand on parle même
de fontenay c'est pareil alors moi l'ont
préféré s'est dit mitchell je ne résiste
pas parce que imafs il m'a réjoui en
disant par exemple si godard fait du
cinéma
moi je suis la femme à barbe donc moi
j'adore parce que c'est hilarant c'est
pas forcément dans les dames il a
forcément drôle mais ça déboulonne des
gens à qui allons te lui m'ont dit non
ça va remercier pas de ce péril la à
cela que je reste moi je rejoins quand
même ce qui a été dit c'est parce que
ç'a toujours été des personnes qui ont
toujours dit ce qu'elle pense et je
trouve ça bien mais est ce cui mai
dernier mondial
c'est un peu des vieux aigris qui
mèneront plus rien à perdre qui slash et
critiquent le travail des gens si on
faisait la même chose sur un an leur
film louise où étaient nazes ou indice
quiz était naze franchement je pense que
on aura notre discours absolument à 100
contre le politiquement correct la
police de la pensée
guillaume t et lloris qui pensent-ils
par livre c'est très bien bravo qui lui
pose des questions et qui se perd mais
franchement de la maltraite en interview
je donne mon avis parce que c'est la
dernière et mer mais aussi bon si c'est
une star qui est de son avis moi quand
je vois belmondo qui est toujours aussi
doux aussi le chant tic et une énorme
star et de longs comme le tas mais
maintenant tout est aigri la vie c'est
de la merde et jenson a dit ahmad nazari
kanak est une vraie star qui vieillit
bien et l'autre qui vient de s'achever
merci beaucoup j'ai laissé un blanc mais
alors